We are socialist youth of the Basque Country.
"Of course we promote participation.
"
of young people in politics.
We are socialist youth of the Basque Country.
Of course we work
for decent employment and opportunities for all.
Euskadiko Left Ligastákara Etanoski
public broomstick takaritas
claims udela.
"We are socialist youth in the Basque Country.
"
and of course we bet
for 1 more sustainable Euskadi
and more respectful of the 2nd environment.
We are socialist youth of the Basque Country,
of course we believe in justice
social and equality.
Bustioy box,
my name is Gabriel
and I am the Secretary General of Youth
socialists of the Basque Country,
1 organization in which we work for equality,
for social justice and for a sustainable future,
and in which we fought to give voice to young people,
for facing job insecurity
and for building a dynamic and vibrant Euskadi.
We are the socialist youth of the Basque Country
and we are here to change the script.
Join us and us to build
1 present and 1 better future